what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel a fan
favorite
auntie jenny everyone loved you thank
you everyone wants to know like your
life story oh i just say as i see it i
just say as i'll see it what can i do
like the only thing i was hoping is that
i can stop them from making the same
mistakes that i made
that's a good attitude because i think a
lot of older women like will sabotage us
and tell us the wrong stuff they did
like i don't know why what do you think
that is i just think it's jealousy that
they know what they've lost and rather
than say oh they were going to help
these young people they're like they're
actually jealous of them because the
young modern girls are where they want
to be
well guys before we start don't forget
to like the video because that's the
most important metric in the algorithm
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell also sign up for our
memberships there's two tiers and the
first tier you get chat privileges on
the second tier you actually get bonus
videos so you see blogs we also have a
discord but today we are watching kevin
samuel's most viral video that made him
famous
it's called your average at best do you
know who kevin samuels is okay
[Music]
can you hear me now
[Music]
hey can you hear me yeah are you a phd
i know i'm a phd
how many dollars you got
i won
really
i'm sorry what kind of dog is it
he's a cane corso
he's a what
a cane corsa
what is that in english
um it's a larger dog and their breed is
meant for guarding and protecting
they're very protective of their home
and their families so what's your
disagreement
um honestly i don't have a disagreement
i just came here because i honestly want
some advice from you
it says disagreement day
oh i know but this is my first time
catching on live normally i'm asleep
and um you have a job
i do i own a business okay so i do too
and i do have a question but i have a
business and if you wanted my advice
you could always book a session if you
can't catch us at the show live
i'm definitely i was trying to go online
um earlier
but all you have to do man see what kind
of business do you own
i want to pet grumman doggy daycare and
okay so
[Laughter]
what do you think so far i'm speaking
number one she's a business owner and
she's called in at the wrong time yeah
she's not even doing a show about that
but she's still insisting and she's in
the right business and she's obviously
gonna be single with a dog when we have
a single women's dog so
she's gonna make a lot of money you know
what's yours are crazy too they they
clipped him right and he went viral and
they're all saying like how mean he was
to her later you'll see but they don't
ever like talk about that she called
another day she was like
i've spoken to her i'd be like sorry
wrong day bye
and hang out what you're basically
trying to do is i have a disagreement
day and you basically came in and said
damn your topic
i want to ask you what i want to ask you
and that's but you are more than welcome
to go on my website and purchase your
time to talk with me one-on-one because
what you're trying to do is rather rude
but i will go ahead and do it because
i'm going to use this as a teaching
lesson
how are you
how old are you i'm 35
35 years old
35 years old and you're a business owner
uh-huh and what's your question
um so
my issue is well i want to know at what
point when i'm
just meeting a guy do i tell him that
i'm a business owner because um my
problem is that
when i try to date down and i the
conversation comes up to where i own the
business um the guy is either like hey
can i come join in on you on that
business or
can i put some money and be a business
partner and
i'm not looking for that and i honestly
oh
hold on hold on hold on hold on i need
to be clear on this subject
where are you where are you at
north carolina have a menace
how would you ever mention it i mean
hello my name is auntie jenny i own a
business like what's up you know i'll
say okay
i don't know anyone who meets someone
and starts with i in the business yeah
you wouldn't would you you know that
would become later on you know once they
know that you're working you've got a
job but you wouldn't start with i've got
a business because ben don't care no
it's not
obviously once she starts pushing it out
there that you've got a business
obviously you're advertising you want
someone to join you so
they're just glad they're joining and
you're saying when to tell somebody you
own a business
because um i find when i date down
god
to your interest and want to be like a
business partner and i'm i'm learning
that maybe i need a high-value man
because that's well first off um
man i really understand uh
what kind of man are you talking about
because owning a business is no
different than having a job in my
opinion
i'm not getting what you're saying when
should you i'm not understanding why
this is an issue
if you're if you're what kind of men are
you what kind of men are you dating
um i try to give i
try to give guys that
not just
you try to do what
i try to give guys that's not on my
level a chance why what do you mean on
your level what does that mean
that's making six figures or more
but i don't under okay
you try to give guys who are not on your
level a chance
why and i'm
because i want i honestly want a six
figure guy um is what i'm realizing okay
so let me just go ahead and edit it out
for you
you ready uh-huh
the guys you want aren't asking you out
well i'm i haven't been putting myself
out there honestly
but you put yourself out there enough
for the guys you don't want or believe
you to ask you out
those are like guys i met online
right so
again
the men you want are not asking you out
see you ladies do this
you go and
deal with men who you feel are beneath
you and then you ask how
to fix them i'm not beneath you i don't
know how to fix a guy that doesn't
that's down there that's not my concern
the better question is why can't you get
a guy on your level
that's the real question it's not
well
well first of all i would tell you
what i said in here automatically is a
problem
why you would come onto a show that you
know was a disagreement day
it's selfish
it's like well yes ma'am it's sell it's
like i want what i want
i don't i don't say things for no reason
that's why i asked you questions you're
35 years old a business owner that means
you understand what business is and you
know this is a business and i have a and
i have a show title and you said damn
your show title i want to talk to you
but you could have went to my business
and booked time to talk to me but you
wanted what you wanted how you want it
i'm sorry
no it's but and i'm using this as a
lesson that's the problem with too many
of you black women you don't do [ __ ] the
right way with black men
that was improper
and when i even when i told you the
right way you still were like uh well
whatever
so i'ma use this
when was the last time you had a
relationship
um right to end it last year around
december how long did it last
a
year a year uh and was that man uh
did you go to college
did i go to college
yes
no sir
okay and how long have you owned your
own business
nine years
and how and how long have you been
making six figures or more
on the last three
okay why do you need a man making six
figures
um because i'm finding out that the guys
that i think that's not is not working
out
what does it have to do with money
because i feel like
um
i need a god that i can respect and
admire and i'm a [ __ ] invention and i
want a guy
that has that drive too and when he
doesn't i find myself you know
encouraging like hey babe you can do
this and you can do that
and then right so in north carolina
how what percentage of the population
what percentage of men in this country
make six figures or more
i think it's like five percent
i'm not
closer to 10.
so
oh 10 all right so
the question is what do those men who
make that kind of money who all women
tend to want
what do they want
i
feel like they want arm candy somebody
who can um
have more to bring to the table than
just looks but um
also bring
balance to their life i feel like i can
help them out on um okay slow down
what do you think those guys want
that money
what her money
her body and their money she's
emphasizing i'm saying the guys that she
wants that don't want her what do they
want hey
because
she's just got she's got no to me she's
got no business sense because obviously
she don't understand how a business
works because she's interrupted his show
how can you be going out with someone i
mean i i hate when people say oh this
person's below me no one can look down
on you unless you put yourself below
them so for her to go out there with
these men she's going out there picking
up men that she knows that are below her
in her eyes
and saying well i've got this money so
let me help you do this and let me help
you do that she's not you know she
hasn't even said well i've got a man
that's got this and we can help him
build
she's just leading with this is what
i've got and this is what i want well
who's going to want that she's 35 she's
got a dog already and she's got no
menace
you know she's got no she's got no
manners so she might as well stay with
her dog
and you know look after all the other
old people's dogs so that's about going
from experience do women like that ever
grow up no never nah but just become old
children yeah oh prima donnas i've heard
someone say that women stop maturing the
second they get attention from men which
is like age 13 and then don't start
maturing again until after it stops well
that means she's never gonna stop issue
she's always going to be immature
because she's always going to get
attention because you can oh come on
look at her she doesn't even look like a
business woman she doesn't carry herself
like a business woman i mean the first
thing when she said that she's a
businesswoman i thought well why are you
calling on the wrong show
i mean that's just common sense well and
the other thing is like i mean i i own a
business too but i don't care with guys
i i don't think i'm better than a guy
just because if i make more money well
she does because she says she takes guys
below her i mean she's going for guys
below her do you think that's important
you have to date a guy that makes more
than you no no no i don't think so
either i've i've never dated a guy that
owns bother me like i just don't because
i think men have value just in like
being mad i mean they have to be like
competent to some degree but like she
reminds me of when these women that
earns more money and then just
shows it i mean i earn more money than
my man and
my mom is irrelevant
you know if he wants to go out and buy
stuff he will go out and buy stuff i'm
not going to say i've got more money
than you you know because i know that
they said i mean look at her she just
looks she's she she doesn't look
business like no no
she doesn't know business i would never
wear that you know like no it's got too
much cleavage the the the makeup the
hair and the dog in the background yeah
i mean that was a big sign for me i
thought she had more than one well and
like i i don't like fake lashes i think
they look really unprofessional
like like i just don't think girls look
good with fake eyelashes i think the
whole fakeness looks unprofessional yeah
the eyelashes the hair
the makeup i mean i was saying to my
boyfriend i said to him i actually
watched someone put makeup on and i said
i remember going to a tinted moisturizer
and you said what are you putting on
that for you don't need it and that says
that would have took me like two minutes
and i said i've watched women put makeup
on it's like five layers
i think like time wise because i don't
really i don't wear a lot of makeup i
just do mascara yeah and i'm like
if i took the time to get good at makeup
and then every day you you have to spend
an hour doing it like that's five hours
a week i'm like i could i could learn
guitar in that time it was ridiculous
they take too long to get ready
and she's took a long time to get ready
i still got it wrong
i'm not understanding you said they
won't arm candy then you contradicted
yourself
you they want somebody to more than just
looks
yeah arm candy but something about you
know brain with it and
you know more in dale do you own do you
know any men who makes six figures or
more
do you think men care about how smart
their girl is but that's not one of
those stupid as a
i'm sorry i'm not saying
and then she's saying that well yeah i
think they do i mean what common sense
yeah yeah and that's what they want
common sense and now everybody's got it
seems like it's easier to get a degree
or a phd than to get common sense that's
what
i say this i said it's because some of
the dumbest people i know are so
educated yep i was like you're the
cleverest stupid person
and the more i do street arguments
there's like a type of person and i know
exactly it's like the same archetype
yeah it's always like
ivy league educated they can
make
the
the simplest argument
complicated yeah for no reason because
they've got the language they've learned
the words they've got to use them
i mean what's the point of that
education when you never get to use your
words so that's what they do every
opportunity they get to use the words
which makes no sense for anybody else
because
it's this nonsense that's what i i think
the smartest people can tell you things
like complicated concepts in the
simplest terms you know but stupid
people take the simplest complex context
and and just stretch it
and make it complicated for no reason do
you know any men who make six figures or
more
my dad and my uncle oh man he does
excuse me do you know any men that you
are related to to make six figures or
more
unrelated to
yeah but you are not related to
not on a personal level
so you don't know him
you don't know what they want
but you want him man
i'm going to suggest that you really
don't know
what you want
and saying six figures is just
something that you've got
taken from out there but i'm not hearing
this rooted to anything
but what do you want ultimately do you
want to be married children what
yes i want to be married
do you want any children
yes
how many
um
i have a son you know so
okay hi is your son
he's 13
where's the father
he's not enough in his life
i said where's the father
well he's
not like in it like i would like him to
be
all right so um go ahead and take this
down man
men who make the kind of money you're
talking about have options
and typically i don't want to deal with
women who are have 13 year old sons who
are used to dating men who
this doesn't sound appealing
to the kind of man you're talking about
do you understand what i'm saying
yeah but um i was thinking once i start
booking session with you
that um i can't change me she's like
yeah but i don't care question now once
you say but it cancels everything that
you said before so it's like yeah but
which means no i just i don't understand
how these girls get these big ass egos
i'm like did you not have brothers to
bully you a little bit
and the thing is she wants a high value
man she you know they say that um birds
of a feather flock together or you're
known by your peers i always say to
people if you go to a nightclub and you
meet a man in that club and he turns out
to be a rave and all these women what do
you expect look who you meant yeah now
if you want to meet a man six figures oh
why are you hanging around with dogs
literally
you know why aren't you going out where
but she looks like someone who would
stand out if she had a man and six
figures because she doesn't she can't
speak properly she's got no manager
she's got no time cleaning she obviously
can't read because she didn't read what
he says so that means that she can't
read a can't use a knife or thought
properly
so how can she get a table with a six
figure man
and she's not dressed appropriately for
a six-figure man and at 35 of her
teenage son all the crap that's on their
face he's not going to make her look any
more better
well and that's that's the thing like
all of my brothers make six figures
they're older than me and they would
never like
the girls with the fake hair the fake
nails the fake eyelashes they don't give
the time of day yeah they don't
so i don't know why she's just able to
like carry yourself she just seems to
think i've got the expensive makeup i've
got all the hair and now i can get the
six figure man why you don't know
anything about them you don't know where
they are otherwise you'd be mixing with
them
so it's obvious that what are you gonna
do if a six-figure man dropped in front
of her she wouldn't know what to do
no
she wouldn't have a clue she wouldn't be
able to converse with him she wouldn't
be able to you know go out and socialize
with him because she's not used to it
because she's not doing that now
if she really wanted to meet a man with
six figures then that should be your
social circle why why do you think the
younger generation is so delusional
because i spoil was do you feel like
your generation was this delusional or
people kind of knew where they stood i
think we never had so many people
helping us to be delusional okay
there's too many people helping you know
the internet and the makeup and it's
like once and the stars they're looking
at all these all these stars you know
the kim kardashians and all the rear
people that are the one-offs and they're
thinking well
i can do that and now anybody thinks
that you just get on the internet you
can be a star when that's what
like a lot of times i see people pushing
like luxury lifestyles on average people
like freezing your eggs and like that
sort of stuff and like botox and like
all all of the stuff that keeps
celebrities looking good it's a luxury
average woman can't do that i get like
25 year olds having botox now and i
think
oh my gosh why are you having a botox
yeah if you're having it now
what are you going to be like in another
10 years
you know it's like the beforehand
it's the lips
it's the lips that i don't like you know
and i thought to myself for years they
were when i was growing that was always
like oh those black people they got big
lips big lips and as a black person i
mean i never read like massive bits but
a lot of people are conscious about
their lips and then like a few years
later everybody wants big lips
and they don't even they don't even you
know there's they remind me if you lick
their lips and stick them on the wall
they will just stick there yeah you know
because they're just ridiculous they
can't talk properly
you know and and the veneers that
they're getting now and their eyes and
oh it's it's ridiculous so i think you
know sometimes i think to myself a man
would get a woman he would take her own
and when he wakes up when he wakes up in
the morning he must think who the hell
are you
you know what did i bring home you know
i don't recognize you and and it's sad
these women are delusional they just
really believe that they've got the
whole package but they've got the
package that they want they haven't got
the package that the men want
otherwise she wouldn't believe then with
how much she earns because how much she
earns is irrelevant having a business is
irrelevant her age and the fact she's
got a 13 year old child rather than
leave with the business you should be
leaving with i'm 35 and i've got a child
the other thing about like what in and
out of style was do you remember it used
to be really skinny girls that were like
the and the media that was what everyone
wanted to look like like lindsay lohan
amanda bynes type of body and then all
of a sudden kim kardashian like bb and
they look like diapers i the diaper
butts well for me i'm the one the most
flattest people in my family and for
years everybody else you could be really
skinny
except for a lot of the black culture
they really like their women chunky
more robust and i was always i was well
attracted by anyone who's who wasn't
black part of me but
my own culture they were like look at
hiccups what's wrong with you
and i'll study like an ironing board no
matter which way you swing her she's
she's flat and then all of a sudden i
would say like right now obese is a new
size 10.
yes
obese is a new size 10. i i've got a
thing about i mean i'm i'm naturally
slim i am actually about four
pounds
heavier than i was 36 years ago oh wow
good for you you need the same size
clothes yeah and i and i look at these
women and
they're not attractive i just think you
just you know any man that takes someone
that's obese now make sure you've got
like health insurance or something
because that's a heart attack waiting to
happen
you know or marry her but insure her
because when she dies which she will be
soon and just keep on feeding her
because she's obviously got no
self-control and can't keep her mouth
shut that is my view because for
instance this is how i think because
i've got a sister i had a sister my late
sister yeah and she died
and everyone kept the phone now oh we're
so sorry your sister died like yeah
whatever and they goes how did she die i
said she committed suicide i know my
family's going to hate me for this but
i've been for this before she committed
suicide and it goes really how does she
do that so she would shut her mouth they
goes well she died because she was
overweight all the illness she's got
because she was fat
and as far as i'm concerned every doctor
says to you you know if you eat this
this this this this you're going to get
fat and you're going to die oh it's bad
for your health and you decide to eat
this this this this this suicide death
by food
wow
i've never thought about it that way
you know it's funny my dad i asked him i
asked my dad questions sometimes like
what i should look for in a guy like
what are the most important things and
one of them you told me is health
because otherwise you're not gonna
they're not gonna live there's no point
you need someone that's gonna
eat healthy
you know or if you can't eat healthy
shut your mouth and look at the
unhealthy food actually question this
i'm curious your stance so my dad said
um i asked him like again traits i ask
him about like traits i should look for
in guys right and one thing he told me i
asked him how he felt about age gaps
and my dad told me that it's not as good
of an idea as the manosphere seems to
think because on the one hand like i
think you get commitment when there's
more of an age gap quicker and you have
more like value to the guy but then my
dad was like no because you'll outlive
him and then you'll spend the last like
20 30 years of your life alone swimming
live longer than that yeah but i'm
curious what do you what do you think
about age gap dating
i've done it all updated younger men
five days older man is your boyfriend
the same age as you know he's younger
younger okay about a few years that's
what my dad said he said you should date
a yoga yeah i'm like dad i don't think
you understand what the 22 year olds are
like
you they've got some quite you know if
you're choosy because i think a lot of
the young men there they're wise and up
to women they're wise and up to the
modern women yeah so
before i'd say like before this modern
women thing started the men were like
boys and you know they were having fun
and playing their games but now they're
looking at them like no
no i think they're tired yeah yeah
they're tired and i know so many young
men that are uh have got
trapped
by women yeah trapped is the word that a
woman sees and thinks you know what
he just wants to have sex with her and
she's just like no he's a good one he's
got no kids so i'm going to be the first
one once i have the first kid with you
you're mine for life you're stuck with
me for life no matter who you got after
me you're going to be stuck with me for
nothing and that's what i always tell
the men i tell my brothers this too i'm
like be careful
these girls are yeah they would and
always say get the condom buy your own
condoms and hold them up to the light
because i've heard about women putting
needles in them pinholes
oh yeah they do that to me that's insane
like why would you want to bring a kid
into a with a dad that doesn't want the
kid to shut the man because it's my
slippery's first and if it's the guys if
it's a man's first child
it means something to him and you'll
find there's a lot of women out there oh
that will trap so do you feel like do
those guys actually end up staying with
the woman or no no no do they love her
no they hate her
i'm just speaking i'm just speaking for
i could only speak from experience yeah
and i've got three grandchildren yeah
right and my son didn't know about any
of them
same woman
any of them don't get me wrong the girl
loves my son to death and they were
really good together but they always had
an agreement no children so when a woman
tells you she's on the pill and you're
in a good relationship
and she was always chunky and then it
seems like every time i went to holiday
and i came back there was another baby
and i told her off and i said you've
robbed me of like you know
baby showers you know buying the clothes
and everything and i'd come back there
was a baby i'd come back and there was
another baby and i'd come back and there
was another baby and i said to myself
where's all the condoms i bought you
you know i'll go out and i'll buy them
for you you know but it's it's and now
he's just like no and that ruined a good
relationship wow that ruined and then
they were like
they could have they were like the best
couple that i know they had the same
business mine they had the same get up
and go and they could make they could
make money out of anything
and just for the fact that
she was a girl for now
not a girl forever and she thought by
having children she would turn herself
into a girl forever
but she isn't she just a girl for now
with three children from the same guy
wow
but she's a great mother and i love her
daily do you think that she um
like would she
do you feel like he would have just like
broken up with her and like had kids
with someone else if that didn't happen
i was definitely and you think she knew
that oh yeah how long were they together
oh they've been together
are they still together they weren't
together when they had the children
every time she got pregnant i didn't get
it because you weren't together you
weren't together and a lot of men it's
not the only one a lot of men out there
are getting trapped by women
and the men you know the men are like oh
it's my child
you know i've got be there for my child
and the women are like you've got to be
there for me too
and then if they're not there
for the woman the women have issues with
it because
i've got your child what that mean and
then and then that's when you see them
use no i'm not saying she did but like
in some cases that they'll get like use
the kids as leverage over the guy that's
not a lot of people do that
i've seen a lot of women do it and they
do it and they don't realize the
consequences because the men just end up
hating them well and the kids grow up at
some point and figure out the truth kids
aren't stupid i was saying those i feel
like at some point the kids figure it
out because they're not stupid like all
my friends that have like crazy moms
at some point they got old and realized
she's crazy my son's one of them yeah
wait yeah wait wait wait
wait
you know when you go up he's like yeah
my mom's crazy he's like yeah i think i
i'm one of them anybody that knows me
will say yeah
jennifer
i know but i can approve myself and i
feel like i have a lot to offer to those
type of me
okay but see
you should have stopped right there
i just told you i cannot change men and
you said once i book a session with you
i'm not a miracle worker i'm telling you
what they want
and you're still saying yeah but i want
them
they don't want you
but i have been working on myself this
year and um
okay ma'am but okay
35
13 year old son with a sketchy father
why would a man
who's in the top 10 percent of earners
who women across the country
want want that
um because i have a lot to offer um i
feel like would you want your son
to
if you had a son making that kind of
money
would you want him to bring home a woman
who had a 13 year old son from a sketchy
father or would you prefer him to get a
woman who had no children who was
younger and easier to get on his program
depending on his age
this is this
see what i mean see what i mean this
goes so deep for black women
they will even that should have been an
easy question
no i would not want my son to bring i
want the best for my son that should
have been the appropriate answer
that's why i sat up
that is [ __ ]
so question
since you were you were a single mom
why are you not offended by this stuff
like why do you feel like you can
actually take it in i think i'm a rarity
i think i was a single well i number one
i got pregnant when i was 17.
i was on the pill so it wasn't expected
it wasn't planned it wasn't expected and
i thought my initial thought was i was
[ __ ] i've messed up this man's life i
always wanted 10 children
personally i want you to have 10
children and i thought oh my gosh you
know we went together and got the pill
and everything
and it wasn't a good relationship but we
went together and got the pill and the
first one that came to mind was it i
think i've done this on purpose
everybody knows that i've always wanted
10 children
and so i actually went and i said like
i'm pregnant
because i thought i wanted you know you
want it you don't want it
i'm happy with that if you don't want it
i'll do my own thing and he is he was
just like you know people when the
people will cross road and get whatever
by bus there's worse accidents
and my doctor actually offered me an
abortion i don't believe in abortion
because i think i said worse accidents
happen
i remember i done everything i i had
lots of male friends always have male
friends lots of mentors and my son
because his dad was absent whenever he
felt like it and i surrounded him by
men
even
my men now when my son was i think four
years old i was actually going to get
him to mentor my son because i thought
he was such a good example
of what a real man should be
but his dad had issues with it he
wouldn't do it but he had issues with it
but what i've issues with this so many
single women that go out there and they
have these kids and
they either tie down the man or you must
do this or you must do that or they just
think they've got the kid and it's like
a handbag but they're still they've
still got it you ain't got it you've got
child you ain't got it i didn't think i
had it when i had my son i just
completely took myself off the market
for the first five years of his life
because i think the first five years are
important and that's all that's who i
concentrated on but they always i didn't
concentrate on me
i concentrated on my son that's the
biggest thing i see with these women
it's all about me and that's what that's
what she said what i heard when she was
talking was but i wanted saying but you
can't i but i want this and i'm working
on myself and i'm doing this and i'm
doing that and i just think to myself
well i just thought to myself that's it
that's what turned me around i remember
kevin samuel says sonic about
having a single child and he said
something about
other men seeing that child and the
father or whatever
and i remember there was a guy and he
was
he wasn't attractive to anybody else
because he was he was a fat guy
but he was so nice
and so kind and he was absolutely
fantastic and reflected for years he was
actually a really nice guy and he was
always chatting me up
and i remember this was a super hasta
and i remember i came out there with my
son
and he goes oh hi darling how are you
going and
i looked at my son he said no
i said what he said don't tell me
he says is that so-and-so's son
and i was like yeah and i thought you
was a good girl never spoke to me again
after that i was guided
i was so upset and i thought to myself
oh my god everybody's going to look at
this child and think that's who she's
been with
so i just had to do it on my own as best
as i could i didn't want nobody want to
see that the quieter child with you know
because they'd be thinking what kind of
person is she but gradually everybody
realized that i wasn't that kind of
person but when you see the dad you just
think to yourself
how could she have a child with him
and then i depicted myself i can't have
a child of anybody else because they're
going to feature themselves i've got to
deal with that crazy man
well a lot of women don't think now they
just think they've got the child and
they do not put the child first i mean
they sit down there and they wait for i
went to college with my with my son
he went to when he was under a year old
i went to college i took him into the
creche and i'd collect my classes give
him lunch put him back in and i'd done
it all but the most important thing is i
made sure that he had lots of men around
him
lots of good men around him who are good
examples but the women don't do that
they've got the child and they're not
looking at the men for their child
they're looking at the men for
themselves and what i hate about england
england pays you to have children that's
the worst yeah they pay you to have
children i was so glad when they stopped
the child benefit after two because i
just think one is a mistake two you got
killers three pay for it yourself why
should i be paying for you to have a
child i was working hard as a single
parent and i had an ex-friend now and
she had a baby and she was planning to
have the next one oh jennifer i'm gonna
have another she wasn't living with a
man she'd have a guy
planning her second child and i'm
supposed to be all happy about it
and when they our friendship stopped
when i said anything a bit strange that
i can afford for you to have a child but
i can't afford for me to have one
because she never worked
and that always worked
and everybody at the time they was like
oh it's crazy because and it is crazy
because you get more money when you've
got a child and don't work
if you
and if you work yeah and then even my
child's dad was saying to me my son's
dad was saying you're stupid to work
what are you working for because you can
get money you know the government gives
you this the gov but i wasn't raised
like that
i was raised you work
if you want something you work for it
but the women out there now is just to i
think that it should stop paying people
to have children
you have the children you work for them
because f women had to work for the
children they want me trapping that and
i say trapping i'll say trapping a lot
of people don't get upset with me
because at the end of the day a man
can't get pregnant
so as far as i'm concerned it's down to
the women to protect themselves i agree
yeah so where if a woman gets pregnant a
man don't know about it she's trapping
him
i mean me unless you're just unlucky
like me you know or yeah the point one
percent of people who condoms aren't
working
but other than that no they they're
trapping them and a lot of nice
well
really good young men out there now are
getting trapped by can i say [ __ ] yeah
you could say okay
yeah they're getting trapped by [ __ ] by
[ __ ] and the thing is what men don't
realize women are devious women have got
this like inner power i mean i can be
anything to any man i'm that confident
in myself girls can i we see it we see
it they don't you could do anything to
any man i mean i mean i'll find out what
is it um hot girl summer yeah
i felt like well that was yesterday and
i was like oh my gosh i must have said
why i said i think i had a hot girl
decade you know and you gotta be honest
about it you know and i just thought to
myself wow
hot girl summer where did this come from
because everybody's going like it's a
new thing no it was an old thing but the
only difference is is that it's not what
you do it's how you do it
you know and
my son never met
any
the only person he met with two men i
had a serious relationship the one i'm
with now
and he met him when he was four years
old
and another serious partner that i had
but other than that he never met any of
them and the women are too easy to say
the children are getting confused it's
like going around in swing doors you
know the front door's a swing that one
guy comes in and the next guy comes out
and the next guy comes in and then they
look at the child and all this you know
everybody's giving the child sweets and
uncle and too many uncles i mean i in my
day there was all uncles you know it was
like who's this this is your uncle but
now the women don't care this is my man
this is so-and-so next week it's i have
a man and yeah and i just think it's so
wrong you know what's crazy i have girls
come on the show right
and i look i know they're single parents
and i see their instagrams after
and i'm like i would be mortified if my
mother was posting her butt on the
internet
i was in a dance group
i was a i was in a dance group with my
my brother and it was a soccer dance
group so we were like basically costumes
on stage you know with the skirts and
everything like that and i remember we
were going
i don't know how old i thought i was but
i also a lot better than this when i was
younger and
the things that they were asking me to
do
and i said i'm sorry i can't do that
and then goes well i said i'm not doing
anything on that stage that i'm not
happy with my son seeing
and they said you see i said no i'm not
doing and i left
and they bought other women to do it and
everybody thought i was going to be
really upset because these girls were
massive
they were
big
chunky girls yeah
they were the fittest chunky girls i've
ever seen and because women are
naturally [ __ ]
when i went to see them perform
everybody thought oh she's going to be
like what'd you think about that i was
like because they were fantastic i
wouldn't have done it yeah because i'd
be thinking to myself that video is
going to come and haunt you
and you know when you have a child 10 15
20 years you know but now it's too easy
to go out there and everybody's online
and it's just sad everything's online
it's like without the internet it would
have been a world would have been a lot
better place if people had to wait but
either you put on your computer you
press the button and that's it we're now
the computer it was like
waiting for the dialogue time and you
never had all of this but now it's like
they've got their children on there
they're on there they've got the boobies
out they got their bums out it's like
it's like an accessory almost yeah it's
like a purse you know i really hate
minnie me's when you see you see the the
mother and then you see the miniature
[ __ ]
because that is what you're raising
there to be
it's a miniature tram and then they talk
about like
like they break up a home so quick like
they're the reasons these girls tell me
they broke up at home i'm like are you
are you nuts people break at home just
sitting right and i'm like you realize
like
like you're that's horrible for a kid to
be raised in a single-parent home yeah
like that's that's horrible for a kid
and right now you have the choice of a
man that wants to be with you and you
tell me he's a good father
well i don't understand why you couldn't
make it work and and because of them
yeah yeah it's because they care about
themselves growing up i always used to
get um i used to always get harassed
slagged off on my female friends because
whenever there was a problem in the
household and they'd sit down and
discuss it with their partner i'd always
take his side and and the women used to
get that yes
because they and you know the one thing
i know about women they don't know how
to shut their mouth if only sometimes
they will shut up and everyone asks you
a question if he says you were where are
you going today oh are you going to the
shops today just say yes oh i'm going to
say sure i'm going to do this they don't
want all of that information they just
want you to just answer the question oh
my gosh you know and they just they talk
too much
running this show
has made me understand my ex-boyfriend's
like frustrations with me when i like
with answering questions
i've never been more in like a man's
shoe and i'm like that's not what i
asked
i'm gonna ask you the same question
again that's not well sometimes women
just went men men just need to be that's
why i gave you that book men need to be
dying women need to be direct because a
man just wants to know yes or no
i mean like you that program that you
was talking about when the women were
blaming their periods and stuff like
that and i was just that infuriated me
and i thought to myself when are women
gonna stop using the fact that they're
having a period for their bad behavior
no
because come on can a man if you're with
a woman you're married with her and
she's gonna have a period for 30 years
that's a poor man got someone for years
well i mean there's so many things out
there i mean this is the land of
technology i know the world's out there
and you're going to tell me that you're
going to suffer every month you've got
even in primrose you've got a whole heap
of stuff but you just want to make that
man suffer i'm sure they do it on
purpose well and that's half the month
because the week before your period and
your period that's how much they did
they just do it that's why you know if a
woman is going on about a period a woman
that's barren just have sex with her
you know forget about the kids so you
don't want to keep because women just
moaned about periods somebody goes oh
don't you mad about your period i said
am i supposed to learn for the you know
for the next 30 years
think about it how long does a woman
have a period and if you're with her my
partner you've got to put up with that
for that long yeah it's not an excuse
for being like having bad things and the
men fall for it
yeah and it's all about it's all a load
of rubbish
i mean and the women get all defended
like every man says oh you're on your
period again just say yes
that's what
yeah and i just thought to myself
please women have it's they got excuses
for everything everything and the thing
is that
they're so good at it so they get away
with it but it's not happening anymore
because they've ended why isn't up to
them so now they've got to try and find
new excuses and i'm dying to think what
they what they're gonna what they're
gonna say you know because the
patriarchy
[Laughter]
there's always something
and it's been rubbish from when i was
young and it's still rubbish now and i'm
surprised that the men haven't that's
why i talk to my nephews i talk to that
you know
i call them my children there's about
hundreds so i'm auntie jenny to about
hundred kids and i talk to the kids and
i just say to them no don't do that you
see that girl over there keep away from
her because she's trouble
you know and this girl over there she's
trouble and that because people and and
nobody talks to her children anymore
they don't actually sit down and talk
every child's got a problem they don't
talk to them
they just
let them go but it's all about the women
nowadays and the women aren't even
having fun being women anymore
well because they they're becoming men
i mean i went out once with my
ex-boyfriend and his girlfriend
and a couple of his friends and they
were really shocked because he came
around the car and opened the door for
me and she just got out but i was so
used i don't open car doors
i'm not a feminist i like men opening
doors for me i like to open doors and i
like to open avocado open and the friend
said we never seen him do that before
but it was so normal to me i said do
what they said are you ready to go out
the driver's seat and come around to the
back passenger seat i opened the door
for you and his girlfriend just got out
on her own
because
he's never opened the door for her she
didn't expect it
and when you get women like this that
say that they want you know a six-figure
man
[Music]
they're gonna stand out like a sort of
thumb yeah they're gonna stand there
like a sore thumb because you know
you're gonna sit there and you're gonna
think oh my god look at all these knife
and faults which men are gonna use
you know things like that and that and
to me manners are important you know
table manners are important
this six figure man and this high value
man and i think with me a high value and
it got nothing to do with money
because
i went out with this guy
and it's like totally
a big fat white obese guy
and then you think you're right he's
from scotland he was whiter than mine
okay you know scott from scotland
and
i ain't more than him
but you'd never know it in our behavior
and even though
we split up i think every guy that i've
been out with
they've always split up
in a better position they've always
always made sure they're better
themselves i mean now he's a
director ceo he's got his own bus
company he does all these charity things
and he's got
that's because of me
that's because of me because there's so
many men out there that are
damaged by women
and that's why it's best to get men and
women while they're young because
either the women have got issues or when
they get older you can see the issues
that
the women
have given the men i mean like i said i
had my hot decade
[Music]
and i knew i had issues and i actually
went and apologized to every single one
for the way i was because i said i had
issues and i actually they were
fantastic men
and i treated them all like [ __ ] because
i had my own issues and they were like
and i went and apologized to all of them
and that's the difference all these
women all these girls are sleeping with
all different men what are the men going
to say about you
well they're going to call you hoe yeah
and and
i would say that in my younger days yes
i was
but
you'd never get any man to say that i
was
nobody that i've ever slept with would
ever say
jennifer why do you think that is
because the way i carried myself my
self-respect
because i even though it didn't work out
i always respected
and they were always the men and i
improved their life
you know because i honestly believed
that if it wasn't for me
scott would never have got married
he never had the business
and he would never have lost weight
and that was because of me
and when he when you know when he told
me i got married i said congratulations
i said you know i'm glad that i helped
you get a good wife he said thank you
because if it wasn't for me he would
have been a wreck because
his ex-wife
she turned him into a woman
oh really that's the only way
she turned him into a woman
and
oh the things that women do to men
is is horrible and the thing is the men
put up with it for the sake of having
this relationship together or they don't
want to be seen as the bad one for
walking out but in most of the men that
i know they would have been quite
justified walking out but they they
stick there and the women milk it the
women know what they're doing they do
they they can you know
women can they've got this thing about
them which the men don't know that they
can be anything i would say i could be
the perfect woman for any man do you
think so um a lot of crimes girls will
leave their baby daddies right and then
i asked them would you be cool if he
moved on tomorrow got married tomorrow
they say yes but i think they're capping
they they're not happy about that
because they always think why me because
i i know quite a few people i i think
they they think the baby daddy will
always be there yeah to like go back
even after they go in the streets but
the thing is it's not that they always
think sometimes the baby's daddy's still
having them oh yeah i know
they they don't know well for now but i
wonder how long that will last
because i talked to a girl she broke her
home up a year ago so like she she could
probably go back now but i'm like she
had three kids out of wedlock and i'm
like what do you think's out there for
you go home you said he was a good dad
as far as i was in an abusive
relationship if he's not abusive
work at it that's yeah that's what
that's what i said i'm like you said
he's a good dad and she's like i waited
till my kids are older i'm like your
son's 8. i thought you said eighteen no
wait
i'm like okay
yeah wait so they wait so they're adults
and then you but i just think women are
just lazy and and it's just too easy
just to
to break it up yeah
you should want the best for your son
of course
but this is
but
and are you thinking
like
if he brought
that's the problem you all think you're
the exception to the rule but but your
life is proven to you that you're not
my love life is not that good i agree
with you that's my point and ma'am and
that's my point
you ladies all feel like listen
you ladies all feel like you're the
exception to the rule
and then when someone like myself comes
along and gives you
a a dose of reality instead of just
accepting it it's like yeah but
yeah but i'm special
you don't know any men on this level
that are not your father that aren't
related to you that means you don't know
these men you don't know where to go get
them you don't know what they want
but you're still saying pick me they
don't want mid 30 year old baby mamas
i'm trying to be polite man but they
don't want those
i asked you a question
did you hear what i said
yes
why is that so okay go ahead
um
my from my point of view i feel like i i
get what you're saying they they do have
better options but also those better
options are younger girls those younger
girls don't necessarily are necessarily
20 year olds are not necessarily
attracted to 45 year olds oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm 51. i can't beat them off with a
stick
that's another one on you lies no
younger women are always the younger
women are attracted to older men what
are you talking about
so can you see me
yes i can
okay so do you feel like a woman like me
uh-huh what would you rank yourself on a
scale from one to ten you cannot use
seven
what i rate myself just your face
uh my face when i wake up five but when
i put myself together six
okay
and how tall are you
five five
dress size
i'm sorry
your dress size
okay so that makes you
if you give yourself a five that's
average
yes so average looking women
tend not to get
high earning men
they tend to get average men
so um did you did you i mean stop right
there stop right there
stop right there breathe and digest
you're 35 years old and you can look
around and see the world
you don't tend to see
higher earning men
with average looking women
off rip
if you do see them they got them they
got their average looking woman when
they were both really young and he built
his way up but a man earning the kind of
money you're talking about does not go
for an average looking woman
i mean my body is not average so but
ma'am you please don't make me say it
say what
i really just wanted some advice i love
you i'm giving you i'm giving you advice
but you're not taking it the advice is
man ma'am
you're average looking at best
i'm taking it in but
okay but you're not accepting the fact
that
okay
average looking women
average looking woman who's older
average looking older woman with a 13
year old son
average looking woman with a 13 year old
son with a sketchy baby daddy
this gets worse every time i say
something and now you're asking for a
man who's in the top 10 of men
you don't qualify for one
and you're making i mean i don't i don't
want to have to go there
but when you put in the all these other
factors
why can't you just get a man that's
an average guy
sometimes i feel like um
in order to fully submit i have to feel
like he's in well then you're gonna then
you're gonna die alone how about that
let me just cut to the chase man uh you
can feel like what you want to but women
like you die alone
straight up
because you think you're better than the
men that you qualify for and the only
reason honestly ma'am that i can see a
woman like yourself really thinking you
deserve more is because you earn more
because you earn more money than most
people around you in north carolina
but if your ass worked at the post
office you would not think so highly of
your opportunities
and that's the reality we don't
men don't care about your money
not the kind of mean that you want we
don't care about your money
it ain't ours we care about the fact
that you are older and you got kids
what do you think i think she's
disrespectful for number one i would
have hung up on houston once she got
that phone now i thought the same that
is so rude you're 35. like i'm 25. i
knew this is 16. and you're just and
he's older than that so disrespectful do
you know the sad thing about it if you
took off the hair the makeup and the
eyelashes she's got a nice face then
she'd be a five or six without waking up
yeah she she like breaks herself yeah
the makeup has made her downgrade
herself
but she's just got you can tell she's
full of herself anyway she thinks that
she's all that i i think we should bring
back bullying in schools
i was thinking she wants a high value
men and she ain't got no manners she had
she hasn't even got basic manners that's
the thing like the first thing is being
polite like and that's the thing my
brothers would never give even just
looking at her they would never get a
girl that like dresses like that this
time of day ever but girls think because
celebrities can do it they can too but
i'm like you're not kim kardashian
you know what's really sad
is that you you say girls and it's women
as well
yeah you're right she's 35. yeah
it's people my age
i sleep in my age
and and they've got the eyelashes and oh
no
it's just wrong okay let's finish the
last five minutes
and you're average
and your reality of your life has showed
you that
you don't have the kind of meaning that
you want
knocking on your door trying to find you
see what we've done in this country this
world is we've told women like yourself
that
you can have it all
and you got a prince charming who's six
foot a hundred six feet tall
six figure income jawline all this other
kind of stuff and i'm sorry man
no
most people get average people
especially average people
you're an average person
i mean let's be real you're not running
microsoft you got you had a pet grooming
business
you've been making six figures for the
last three years
okay
but if i'm looking at you but if i
looked at you and i took all that off
for you
all the eyelashes and all the hair what
do you look like under there
i mean i look the same i'm just no you
don't because if you did you wouldn't
have all that on
i'm sorry
no you don't you don't look the same
because if you did you wouldn't have all
that on
so
for
uh
all right i'll tell you my advice man
because you're not listening to me
that's why i always recommend you nate's
new natives need therapy
everyone people think most of us in
black community need therapy but you're
not you're not dealing with reality
i asked you about your child's father
and you couldn't answer me but it
doesn't sound like you're too proud of
him
how's it what kind of student is your
child
he's a a student
does he have any behavioral problems
no he actually got a youtube channel and
he's trying to don't need to i don't
need no no no
but where is it but his daddy is still
if his daddy is alive
does he have a relationship with his
father
then what's your issue with him
um he's not um business-minded like my
father and my uncle and then why'd you
choose to make a baby with him before
you got married
young and dumb i was 16. exactly and
that cost
see
that dumb [ __ ] let me stop you right
here that young and dumb [ __ ] you black
women throw out as if it's supposed to
get
listen and listen well
women young and dumb is not a get out of
jail free card it doesn't go okay
she changed the fact
she's 35 but now she was 16 when she had
him like the math doesn't make sense
you still have to carry that consequence
and men are not rushing up to be
stepfathers to 13 year olds
what would be better is if you honestly
sat down and ask yourself what value can
i bring to a man
and i know that what i can well
all right what can what value what what
is it
what is it
i can help him with his business i'm
very business minor on the um end of
health and organizer and
i plant um into planting my own garden
so
i can definitely plant i'm into um
improving my evidence with um
just self-improvement and
working on myself and ma'am at 35 years
old at 35 years old here's what you told
me
i can help him with his business due
respect ma'am
um and i mean no disrespect but 20 to 30
of people own businesses what about the
70 to 80 of men who don't own them
that means that doesn't matter
it's like she's saying she's saying
nothing that means nothing to the
average man
then the next thing you said
i can plant
ma'am that means nothing to most people
because we go to grocery stores then you
say
self-improvement you've had
i gave you a shot at saying what you
have to offer to me and you said nothing
that we value
what do you think what you got booker
sessions
nope nope nope i'm done i'm done i've
tried to go around but this happens the
older you ladies get the more you get
set in your ways book a session because
i don't want to do this in public man
cause you seem like a sweet woman but
you don't but you're not getting it
you're being so mean i'm not being don't
tell me i'm being mean
well
i'm about to be mean
what would you tell her book a session
he also what can she bring to the men
yeah she didn't say anything about she
lost my mind i mean what the hell is
planting got to do with
what men want yeah she didn't say oh i
know what went on i'm ambitious and i've
got this and i can plant and i can help
him with his business that means she's
looking for somebody with a business
what would you say men what if they're
the good mother and that sounds sick
they want someone like their mom but
sexier
no that's what they want they just want
they don't want nothing much
i mean she's going on about her business
and about being the high earner and i
remember i was working hard and i dated
this guy i was only more than him but
everybody was surprised that i used to
get up and do his lunch
pack his lunch for work and he'd get
breakfast lunch and dinner and i
remember this guy and he was married and
he looked and he says well you got your
lunch box and i think he had steak and
cheese baguette or something
and the guy says well i'm married and
look what i've got to make my own
sandwiches cheese and your sandwiches he
said i can't believe it and people like
where did you get that time to do that
and i said but a real one would
you know a real a real one wouldn't the
time she spent on her makeup she could
be doing something other than doing her
makeup she's been planting or educating
herself do you feel like women don't
want to compete for a man nowadays they
don't think they have to yeah but they
do when does life start to hit women
hard would you say what age does reality
hit from the girls that you knew when
you were younger that were delusional
did it ever happen there's illusional
ones now oh they're still there's the
original ones now because now what
they're doing they're looking at the
good men like my man and they've got
teenage kids and they're thinking either
woman approach
my man in front of me i walked away
and he spoke to me and i and he was it
was an ex
it was it was one of his ex exes
and she just came and she was like i can
never whisper in you know if it wasn't
for you we could be together mm-hmm and
i was thinking
are you ready to come here and say that
on his birthday
i'm seeing it so i just left the room
because i don't punch her like so very
old lady that he wouldn't appreciate
that i i just separated myself and i
said that
you know what i'm like
and you just told me exactly what you
thought about her
there is no way that she could not of
hercules very vocal about it but exactly
what you thought about and you said come
next door and i just went back in the
room but she was just it's way because
it's like the tables have turned because
like when you're young you see it from
up but from my point of view now it's
like you've got the men that are like 50
like my man you get the men in their 50s
and then you get these women they're
like 35 and 40 with teenage kids chasing
them oh
and i'm looking and i'm thinking you
don't want you
you know
you don't and the thing is i just put
started in the way where i don't expose
who she is the thing is they will send a
man they they don't know what a man
likes
they like me and i have to cover my
knees which one these are kind of
they will send a man pictures of them in
bikinis and all this and that and
thinking that's what the man wants in it
and it's not it's not at all all the
thing they think that and when a man
wants they're not and they're chasing
these men
because now they realize that they can't
get around their age they can't get a
man younger than them they can't get
this older man with all the money so now
they're looking at the regular
nine-to-fivers that are good that
they've watched being steady over the
years i think oh yeah i'm caring for you
and the men don't want them now because
you didn't want me before when you
thought you could go and get these
high-value men and i've been doing my
steady nine to five and now they don't
want you and you're old and you've got
kids and how so how old does that when
when does that happen for women would
you say forty five you said that there's
no
young people 35. it's happening about 35
and that's when they start going yeah
and if they've had children if they've
got teenage kids and they're younger
than 35 you'll find that it starts for
soon as their kids teenage years
because you you seem to find i think
what it is is that when a child's at
primary school the parent the mother
always has to be there
but when they go secondary school
you know you can leave the child at home
so then they reckon that yeah the
child's out i can go out and find myself
someone but you still got that child
she's not thinking about the child he's
still a child
she's thinking oh he's old enough now he
could do whatever the child she or she
can do whatever they like and i'm gonna
go and find someone for myself but the
men
if they were good mothers
and they concentrated on the child maybe
they might attract a man but they're
selfish but they're selfish they're
thinking about me and
like for my man the one thing that stood
out against with all the women that are
chasing him is that
they were put in chasing him before
their children and to him children were
more important and sorry because he's
looking at how how is she treating her
child how can you leave your child you
know say at midnight and come to visit
me your child's at home on their own
and you get to when you're younger you
don't care leave your child i'm gonna
have sex with you anyway you can go back
to your child but as you get older the
men's priorities change they think i
don't want that
so you they all put
so the men can just see how selfish they
are yeah and the women are getting
i think they're getting more and more so
oh so they're getting more selfish i
think yeah because they're getting old
no they're not they're just getting
dumber it's just like getting dumber and
dumber and i don't understand
it's like
all this red pill man is fair i got clue
what it means i don't care
you know because
my life is great without it
my life is great without the internet
you get what i mean so that's not
important but now you get people my age
that
you see them all the time and
with their phones and what are you doing
everybody's got their phones and
everybody wants to be and it's really
embarrassing because you go on tick tock
and you find women older than me
oh my god
i think to myself oh my god you're old
why are you doing it i think about this
all the time especially with the girls
in the show we go yeah kids why are you
naked
and they've got people on there and they
would drag the children around let's all
dance together because everybody gets
famous you know because they were on
tick tock or whatever and everybody's
into the frame and the hype now there's
no foundation and i'm so i'm so glad i
didn't grow up with my mom doing that
i'm always chilling
um well so what did you think of the
video overall that's what made kevin
samuels famous watching it you don't
think he was mean or harsh to her i
don't think he was bloody i i would hang
up the phone
if you if
if i'm saying to you
this is what i'm doing i'm doing it on
this time and then you're going to come
and think you know what such what you're
doing i'm going to say we're going to do
this i would have hung up i'll be like
your business woman but then you should
know that you can read this is the title
come back again and hang out she's got
such she's got all that money but yet
she won't book time with him now
that was so important yeah she'd pay the
money i've once he said to me oh you can
go on
i'm so sorry i'll go and book it i'm
sorry sorry i didn't realize and hang
out she just made herself look stupid
that's what i was thinking i'm like if
you have all this money like the
obsession should be nothing to you
especially this he wasn't as big then
and that's why like one thing said that
people need therapy and i don't think
they it's like therapy is like a bad
word mm-hmm fabry's actually i have a
therapy i look cognitive forever it was
great i actually asked for it
because it gets to a stage where you
think you know it can't be the whole
world it's gotta be me but these people
nowadays they don't know it's them it's
everybody else but me but i thought to
myself everybody can't be wrong it's got
to be me so let me go sort myself out
well that's what i think i feel like i'm
a big believer and everything's your own
fault like like everything in life like
i think if you keep like his girls would
be like oh he was toxic he was toxic he
was toxic and i'm like okay one maybe
but if you keep you know and even even
even with the one like it's like it
takes two to tango my
son's dad was
off the scale abusive mm-hmm that's only
happened to me once um if i keep on
putting myself in there there's
something wrong with me
and i'm not going to carry over what
he's done sorry into the next one and to
the next one and that's what men do i'm
not i'm not going to come compare mm-hmm
you know people say oh i'm gonna compare
this one to this one or my ex didn't do
this so they're just not the same
because your last person cheated on you
and your mind happens to go out for too
long he's cheating on you no you've got
issues left yeah you've got issues and
they don't stop they just carry on and
carry on and carry on and all this uh oh
you know it's because of my childhood
i'm so tired of hearing people talk
about their childhood it's not like shut
up you're richer than most people ever
have been in all of human history even
if you're poor i don't i can't say i had
one of the easiest childhoods but you
know what
my mom and dad they ended up getting
divorced
oh it's because my mama that's my mom's
trauma that's not mine yeah over the age
of life it's nothing to do with me
because i'm an adult
maybe it affected me when i was a child
but
look in the mirror you're blaming
everybody else and say what's in front
of you and that's what they're finding
excuses for i'd like to know what she
done their son's dad because she wants
to look to me like i'm earning more
money than you
probably get rid of because that's what
she seems to think she just seems to
think that she needs someone with so the
people want to know are you going to
start a youtube channel
i think they want it they'd like to see
you on a channel
maybe maybe i wouldn't even know how to
i just have you seen what i post on
youtube it's just food no i don't know
but i just do food
i i just do food anything i post on
youtube has been food and all of a
sudden i've got all these people you've
got a new subscriber
it keeps on popping up on my phone i
think i put a couple of you know i put a
couple of recipes on there but i thought
i'd put anything on this
well if you guys want to learn food you
want to tell them where they can find
you or no either or is fine they're only
going to find food yeah if they want to
you know just maybe they're just meeting
maybe there's some women that want to
learn how to cook
the thing is is that they're expecting
me to do the same thing
as they saw in your podcast
because that's the funny thing is that
that's what everybody's into yeah isn't
it yeah and i think it must be really
strange that i'm doing a podcast and
youtube don't mean anything to me
i don't even know that youtube shows
films you know until last week somebody
said yeah you can watch films on youtube
i'm like you seriously yeah yeah yeah
you know because that's when you want me
to be a guest and i'm in the area fine
great
i've got an opinion on everything
me too me too
and the thing is is that my experiences
of my life will blow your mind and it's
like i always tell people i'm a rarity
i'm not the norm
and so when i when i was telling people
oh you need to do this you need to do
that it's not because i know it all
because i've been for it you've loved it
and i can't think of and other than
being married which was my fault because
i'm not married but other than being
married i can't think of
anything
and i'm thinking anything
that you can say that i have an
experience
well
yeah but i don't let you hold me back
i'm not a victim i'm a survivor and i
always say to people that it's like oh
yeah my mind beat me i feel like you
know the a13 the
it's the you know from answers the great
what you call highway the great big
highway with the bridge just there
imagine being sitting down there naked
and pregnant oh sure right
so i've seen it all but i'm not going to
hold me back because at the end of the
day it wasn't he had his shoes
right and they can deal with it mm-hmm
and gone other days when i think because
sometimes when you sort of like get in
yourself and you think oh you know and
then afterwards i thought what am i
hiding away from i haven't done it i've
been
not my problem it's down to him you know
i mean oh and he's dead now but i got to
the point where i told everybody i got
i went out there and that's why he goes
why are you saying everyone said i
didn't do anything wrong
you know my mom my dad i told everyone
but nothing so i got an opinion about
everything
okay guys um you guys can go to her
youtube if you want to learn recipes
right i think we're gonna do a cooking
video at one point maybe next month
she's gonna teach me and just how to
cook yeah um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out and we'll talk to you next time